patani in thailand's deep south has the
air of a sleepy town as people begin the
day
but there's something more here
something the officials and army want to
keep in the shadows
for nearly two decades along with two
other provinces the military has been
fighting an armed separatist movement
the deep south used to be a muslim
sultanate today it has a population of
80 percent malay speaking muslims
some who have been detained by security
forces say they were tortured activist
ismael says he was forced at gunpoint to
confess to being a separatist the army
denies ever using torture
they want to protect themselves they
don't really care about the victims they
deliberately deny all torture
allegations but human rights groups have
solid information about torture cases
but he sees some good news coming even
though thailand is a signatory of an
international convention against torture
and forced disappearances it has no laws
against it
but a bill will be tabled in parliament
next month proposing such regulation
military leadership here in the deep
south tell us they welcome the laws on
torture and forced disappearances but
they think it's mainly to reassure the
public they say that there have been no
abuses by the army because their
soldiers are trained to respect human
rights
we have been operating based on a good
moral compass it doesn't matter if we
have this law or not in fact we have
been accused of crimes we did not commit
but according to ma these are not just
rumors he says his abductors were
careful not to leave marks on him to
hide their actions
one of the officers said why won't you
confess later they told me that i was
part of violence incidents but i told
him that i was not
i was kicked and slapped but i didn't
say anything they stripped me naked and
tied me up they put a blindfold on
then they used a rubber band to hurt my
testicles
attacks by separatists are still taking
place but the frequency has decreased
ongoing peace talks have started and
stopped several times over the years
never fully taking hold
the army has a big footprint in the deep
south to combat the separatists
and conduct humanitarian missions to
help allay suspicions of the local
people
but ma feels that for some the damage is
already done
people who are wrongfully tortured
suffer ongoing consequences young people
can't return to school they can't get a
job
pet songbirds are commonplace here
displayed in small ornate cages on show
for all to see it's hoped that
thailand's anti-torture bill will afford
the well-being of its prisoners that
same transparency scott heidler
al-jazeera patani thailand
joining us by skype from bangkok is
sunai pasuk senior researcher human
rights watch many thanks for joining us
on the program
thailand has a dark history of torture
and enforced disappearance give us a bit
of context here as to why that is the
case and how this law could make a
difference
well it has long been recognized that
enforces appearance and torture
a serious problem in thailand the un has
recorded over 80 cases of enforcers
appearances
none of them have been resolved human
rights believe the actual number
could have been much higher than that
but because the victims and their family
are too afraid to come forward and and
and tell the truth of what's going on to
the loved one so
that is on this on on one side and then
the other side of the coil is torture
which is commonly used by the police by
security forces by anti-drug units
and and and without
any law
to recognize these heinous practices as
as criminal offenses
perpetrators these law officials
continue to use torture and enforce
disappearance
as they wish without fear of being
punished and if they were caught they
are not punished for
committing
enforcers appearances or torture
at base they were they were convicted
for assault or holding someone against
their will and for enforcers appearances
there is no body there's no murder
so that is the basis of why
there is such a deep rooted
impunity in thailand and why
torjen for enforcer's appearance
continue to exist
how confident are you that this bill
will pass
previous attempts
to get it through have failed
well
i am
to be honest i will say that i
cautiously welcome the move by the
parliament which
unanimously approved the first reading
of the draft law but the draft itself as
proposed by the government is still very
weak
not in full compliance with
international standard so i hope that
the fitting which just started last week
uh will improve
the language of the of the draft to make
it in line with intellij standard that
is one thing but
equally important
is
why the law hasn't been
in effect yet the thai authorities the
thai government
should demonstrate their commitment and
sincerity in ending in forces appearance
and torture by stop all practices that
lead to
torture and false disappearance so
arbitrary arrest secret detention in
communicate or detention
all these practices need to stop now but
on the contrary no the government
has not listened to calls made by
international and domestic groups that
um police unit
security forces that carry our counter
insurgency in the deep south or
anti-drug units they can no longer hold
anyone that will in secret in
communication okay
so next is
basis of the the public
doubts whether the government is serious
about
ending torture and enforce discipline or
they simply want to have a law that will
be uh shown to the international
community that thailand
has or is going to criminalize culture
and enforce experience but the practice
will continue to be the opposite
okay
thank you for your thoughts sinead pasha
a senior researcher human rights watch
speaking to us there from bangkok
thank you